we bought into a lie that confidence is  belief in self and so when you're in a  situation which is normal where you  don't believe in yourself you're like oh  my god i have no confidence the truth is  and i want you to walk out of here with  a new definition of confidence  confidence is the willingness to try  because when you try and you take action  what happens and what's happened for  france is that  when she sees herself taking action  what happens is she sees herself being  the kind of person that takes action so  she has evidence  that she can rely on herself and that  action is what builds confidence it  doesn't start with belief the real way  the real way for most of us is not to  wait to believe but to push ourselves to  act and through the action you will  build the belief